الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون كان في
زياره لمعرض باريس الدولي للزراعه والتقى
مع عدد من المزارعين والفلاحين واستمع
لمخاوفهم وخلال الجوله صار الموقف اللي
راح تشوفوه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اللي شفتوه انه معجب ولا محب حابب يقرب
ويسلم على ماكرون ولا بيصرخ علشان صوره
معه لا اللي شفتوه عدد من ناشطي المناخ في
فرنسا هاجموا خلال زيارته وطالبه بالمزيد
من العمل لمواجهه التغير المناخي وتطور
الموقف مثل ما شفتوه تدخل الامن والحراسه
علشان يبعدوهم وفي منهم بيظهر انه تم
اعتقالهم على ما يبدو وطبعا كلنا نعرف
الاحتجاجات اللي بينظموها ناشطين المناخ
في العالم بشكل مستمر وتحديدا في فرنسا
بسبب التغير المناخي واعتقاداتهم ان
الحكومه الفرنسيه فشلت في مواجهه التغير
المناخي وبترتكب جرائم مناخيه لكن عموما
المقطع ذكر الناس بمواقف عديده لهجمات
تعرض لها الرئيس ماكرون اللي يعني مو من
الرؤساء اللي محظوظين كثير صراحه في هذا
الجانب والاعتداءات عليه تنوعات من الصف
لرشق بالبيض لغيرها